hey guys Ryan right here right now it's
about 7:30 in the morning and I'm gonna
watch the movie clip for spider-man 2
called freefall cuz we can't get enough
of these spider-man 2 clips no no no
before you know they're gonna release
the entire [ __ ] movie anyway I'm
gonna watch this real quick because
there's some reason I like to do this
right before I gotta go to work real
fast
I was not fired yesterday they put up
security cameras inside of the office
that I work at and two things happened
one they noticed I'm going on YouTube a
lot and cuz I'm replying back to
comments so they got a little bit pissed
off about that second thing is they
noticed that while they were gone for
two days that I would just disappear
into the blind spot of the camera for a
few hours and it was because uh I was
sleeping sleep for a long period of time
one of my co-workers snitched on me and
confirmed that I was sleeping I'm gonna
find out who said it other thing is my
landlord is right outside like right
outside my apartment sweeping so I might
have to keep my voice down but yeah I'm
really excited to see this may I I can't
get enough of these spider-man clips man
I just want to see this movie already so
let's watch this thing
and American Hero
good daddy the effects are awesome it
looks real
whoa
damn is he shot so good
I didn't think they can make the spider
mount web slinging look cooler holy [ __ ]
oh dude that's a great tease man they
they amped up the experience of
spider-man web slinging by far that
looks really [ __ ] cool oh my god
yeah whoa short-lived it doesn't really
show much in the movie but damn that's a
great tease because it's like look how
awesome this movie's gonna [ __ ] me I
mean if there's one thing you got to get
my hair look so weird there's one thing
you got to get right about this it's the
spider-man web slinging sequences and
they look like they improved it I didn't
think they could improve it much but
damn they they brought it to a whole new
dimension this is gonna be awesome in 3d
well thank you guys for suggesting that
to me I wouldn't have known about this
clip if you guys didn't tell me about it
so if you're new to the channel this
says subscribe by the way subscribe
please
oh speaking of subscribing gotta give
some shoutouts first off Shane McGarrett
you comment off and can't reply back for
some reason don't know why there's a few
you guys if I ever hit the thumbs up
button to a comment that means I
couldn't reply for some reason and I
love replying to you guys but for some
reason it won't allow me to so fix your
[ __ ] account so I can reply back you
people other's ass other guy Ryan Bell
he said that I inspired him to make some
videos and I thought that was a major
[ __ ] compliment so Brian Bell you made
my day with that comment thank you so
much you ever come around here sucking
your dick and of course new hot ass
female subscriber Twisted Sister oh nine
saw this woman's thumbnail she is fine
if you guys happen to see your comment
you can talk to her too Twisted Sister
oh nine your name kind of freaks me out
it sounds like you're into kinky [ __ ] I
love to see spider-man do stand-up
comedy today I was surfing the web